it was a lacrosse ball there luckily wouldn't
settle down for the guys in red in front of the
net as soken steps out of his goal to play it
gave it away and a chance for Austin zaric and
nearly Bank it in on the exchange for Raymond
again on three minutes without a whistle now
since that early Puck out of play as Bo horac
comes charging in he's got a step and he chipped
it just wide got it to the forehand but miss
the N big Improvement for the Red Wings and
you knew at some point in time with all the
the draft picks and eisman's pedigree that
something good was going to happen one covered
up by sroi corvac wrap around in front baral's
backand wide Lee to barzel horac calls for it
gets it husso the save and he made another oh
a great sequence of Saves by Billy huso now it's
Romano blows right by the Red Wings and now they
all go to work good Puck reval good communication
and this is a pass on the slot nice save by whoo
and then even better one against barzel so these
guys take another look watch him stretch get all
the way across and then the veteran David Pon
Twisted behind the N for Comfort Walman stick
snapped in half pull cleared it away came right
to Pon battle forward to the side of the net and
it's pushed away those guys were flying in the
first and they go opposite C Pon and comfor here
to open the second period of play first of three
meetings between the Islanders and the Red Wings
took it then misfired on a pass Nelson from his
knees attempting the center head off the outside
of the cage roctober needs to come alive in this
game his last chance to right to score LK to the
front and Raymond taed wide B wrist shot tipped
wide I think hrom excuse me walstrom got a part
of that here's Holstrom to Balo intentionally wide
play it perfectly for walstrom and the shot along
the ice stopped and covered by by whoo won't have
to worry about it now walstrom knocked out of the
air by pageo trying to pick it up on the other
side of cider and he did but didn't get much
on the shot and Ryan pulak earlier got that one
you can see he's paralyzed he's immobile he can't
move and that sort of leads to a little bit of a
chaos in front of that that and you see Romanov
with the push here and that's just enough but
Ryan pulock wore that one right off the foot and
he's in some discomfort right now Paul marray for
Nelson Nelson and bul du couldn't get it here's
a two-on-one zornick zornick Wade shoots and it's
off the knob of the Stick of sroa nearly knock it
out of his hand chips in the back of the jerseys
of all these players it's really remarkable stuff
here's a backhand Chance by walstrom trying to
fight it through but it's whoo in a full split
down to make another save now one of their top
penalty Killers available now P Holstrom pel and
pulloff as the brink has a step the brink gets
in Saved by sokin Pell gets the rebound away
from the goal landed on the stick as transition
they're going to come right back at you another
time right there again the Islanders here's
sprung with speed Daniel sprung and a glove
save by S he just makes it look so easy and that
puck hits the broken stick of Paso who's now off
the ice now to Brink it carries in wrestled away
from him by cus morvat hustling cikas has a step
he's in and a score it's in a short-handed goal
from Casey [Music] [Applause] cikis P of the puck
close right in on De Brink steal the puck and then
watch Casey he doesn't hesitate he just goes hard
hard hard out skates and then tries to go five
hold successful who so couldn't hang on do it but
look at the speed of cikas we're talking about the
centerman all night about how much jump they had
now when you're you're surrounded by a little
bit better players and especially with a guy
like Dylan Lin who's a terrific playmaker
that's going to help you here's Kyle Paul
maray not the pass through for angal bounce to
the net and that one eludes whoo but was well
wide and Raymond behind gave way to angal angal
looking at Dobson Dobson one timer [Applause]
score an opening minute goal here
in the third and it's two nothing
Islanders Islanders with a couple of good
opportunities they get it in deep that's
just oldfashioned for checking keep it
in behind the net and Ang ball gets those
feet moving makes a good play Nelson
if anybody may have gotten a stick on
it he was in position there's no question about
that it looked like it was deflected you can't
ask anymore for a guy that's supposed to be
the backup I want the flex off the outside of
the cage Paso with barzel and Holstrom out again
here's Ras M with spraw Daniel spra drag shoots
and scores Daniel sprong puts the Red Wings on the
board and it's a two- on hockey game with lots of
time left and the Islanders are back they've got
numbers it's just a Two on Two And bulld du just
gets caught in in in between and now you lose your
lose your balance there with AO gets beat there
oneon-one late in your shift those are situations
that when you know you're trying to force
something shot by wman couldn't make it through
the bodies in front that one's off AO and then
wman again and they score that might have gone off
someone in front of the net no maybe not pick up
Lin picks up the puck so it might be wallman's
first goal Jake wman let go of the shot in front
of the net some crazy hop there trying to whip it
around and I'm not sure if Ryan poock screened his
go Pender or not it was a knuckle ball yeah that
one that one move for sure Red Wings have scored
twice here in the middle stages of the period a
minute 40 seconds apart cider side the net it's an
open goal for JT comfor it's just nobody picks up
on the far side as he circles the wagon and that
that's on Tuesday in an overtime L to Seattle
as wvac sticks it around towards Nelson now
doson barzel Horvat [Applause]
score ball horv one time on the power play it's
tied well that's a play they've been looking for
over ever since the start of the season a lot of
his goals in that same area watch Horvat number
14 as he gets up higher than normal he's got to
be able to clear the defenseman and he just wires
that one I mean he gets it all perfect pass by
barzel and just drills it by the go tender huge
goal for the Islanders as I said percentages don't
matter Brendan it's when you score them and if you
score them when you need him Romano will take
it behind the net and move it for Ryan pulock
Islanders had a two nothing lead then had to rally
for a late goal to tie it and this game is headed
to overtime Ras M wman and Lin the three- out for
the Red Wings off the draw Lin came away with it
but lost it but it's gathered up by Ras m in the
initial possession what a goal that would have
been for Adam right here's the brink at the NHL
leader in goals handing off for lin Lin had it
roll away from him regathered in front soken oh
my goodness a game saer it's it's three on three
and and the Islanders all all three guys go at the
puck carrier and soken a beautiful pass from Lin
and look at that move as sokin gets there early
the Bret doesn't get it up Brendan cuz he thinks
well i' got it barzel driving to the net I like
that let the shot go the 21y old with speed trying
to get around barzel kicks it over and off the
crossbar goes comfor Corvette trying to secure the
puck gave it away Raymond comfor comfor Raymond
scores game over the Red Wings a 43 win over the
Islanders